woher kommen die träume und warum können
wir sie beeinflussen und so unsere welt
im traum erträumen
wie das geht und warum wir träumen und
wie träume von blinden aussehen jetzt
den klingt zum science fiction hier
gibt's täglich spannende science videos
abonniert den kanal und activity glocke
nur dann verpasst du nichts los geht's
herzlich willkommen heute mit jakob vom
kanal breaking lab das wort traum kommt
ursprünglich vom wort trum was so viel
wie trügen oder trugbild bedeutet doch
sind unsere träume auch nur coop bilder
und woraus bestehen sie überhaupt schon
seit dem neunzehnten jahrhundert wissen
wir dass träume festen abläufen folgen
jede nacht träumt ein gesundes gehirn
dabei werden in der regel vier träume
erlebt dass bis zu zwei stunden des
schlafs einnehmen kann
die meisten träume durchleben wir in der
rem in der rapid eye movement
schlafphase diese erkennt man daran dass
die augen schnell hin und herwandern und
das ganze natürlich im geschlossenen
zustand und trotzdem sehen wir bilder
sigmund freud hat ein ganzes buch zum
thema traumdeutung geschrieben seine
theorie in den träumen verarbeiten wir
die dinge die uns besonders beschäftigen
erfreut kennt weiß dass der mann zu
großen emotionen geneigt hat und so
spricht er davon dass wir in den träumen
unsere größten wünsche und verbotenen
fantasien ausleben
heute sind sich die meisten
wissenschaftler einig dass er hier
überinterpretiert ja es ist wohl eher so
dass wir einfach das träumen was gerade
am besten in unserem gehirn zugänglich
ist und das ist in der regel das an was
wir als letztes gedacht haben aber was
bringen uns träume dann zum einen
ermöglichen sie uns dinge zu tun die wir
in der echten welt nie tun könnten
und zum anderen haben forscher bewiesen
dass wir durch die träume auch lernen
als experiment hierzu hat man probanden
das luzide träumen beigebracht meisten
kennen das wahrscheinlich zum beispiel
aus dem film inception
dort ist leonardo dicaprio in der lage
träume zu beeinflussen und sogar in die
träume von anderen menschen einzubrechen
grundlage hierfür dürften die luzide
träume sein
dabei ist der geist des menschen so
aktiv dass er die kontrolle über seine
träume hat eine fähigkeit die man
durchaus lernen kann eine einfache
methode hierfür
der realitätscheck dabei fragt man sich
selbst immer wieder ob man gerade träumt
dabei macht man die traumwelt daran fest
ob ungewöhnliche dinge passieren im film
inception ist es dieser kreise der nicht
aufhört sich zu drehen was er natürlich
laut den gesetzen der physik auf unserer
welt machen müsste hat man den punkt
erreicht dass man erkennt dass man
gerade träumt hat man es geschafft mann
ist nun in der lage die eigenen träume
zu manipulieren da man geistig wach ist
und gleichzeitig weiß das ist keine
realen regeln gibt und man die macht hat
alles zu verändern und mit dieser
fähigkeit ihre träume zu beeinflussen
haben die probanden aus der studie die
ich am anfang angesprochen habe nun
übungen gemacht und man konnte das
tatsächlich sehen dass sie eine erhöhte
anstrengungen hatten und es gab auch
lernerfolge also haben träume durchaus
einen praktischen nutzen all diese
funktionen sorgen dafür dass die
hirnaktivitäten während des träumens
extrem hoch sind da könnte man sich
fragen ob der körper in dieser zeit
überhaupt regenerieren kann
interessanterweise ja und zwar extrem
gut die hohe durchblutung sorgt
wahrscheinlich für eine regeneration des
nervensystems ähnlich über einen
abschluss würden dann den traum einmal
alles durchgespielt werden wenn man die
hirnströme während des träumens misst
kann man feststellen dass die bereiche
die für das sehen zuständig sind
sozusagen hellwach sind die augen sind
aber geschlossen also sendet das gehirn
an sich selbst signale die unsere
großhirnrinde als gesehene bilder
interpretiert doch was sind das für
bilder wer bestimmt was wir träumen das
ganze wird eindrucksvoll deutlich wenn
man sich fragt was ein blinder mensch
träumt
hierzu habe ich einen interessanten
bericht gefunden wo ein von geburt an
blinde mensch sein traum beschreibt
ich kann in meinen träumen nicht sehen
ich sehe weder bilder noch haben noch
dinge oder menschen in meinen träumen
spielen sich die szenen wenn die träume
ruhig verlaufen und nicht als so sehr
durcheinander geraten fast so wie in
meinem wirklichen leben ab ich kann
dinge und menschen berühren kann die
stimmen der
schon von denen ich gerade träume hören
und kann mich mit ihm unterhalten nur
sehen kann ich sie nicht können computer
träumen vielleicht in zukunft aber ob
und wie sie beziehungsweise künstliche
intelligenzen denkt das beantwortet
breaking lab und zwar in diesem video
ich berühre ist auch dabei also
anklicken anschauen und breaking
abonnieren haben wir kanal mit extrem
tief recherchierten geschichten
wir sehen uns da bis dann bleibt brand